[Music]
I think everyone in the room will agree
that our is a very active community some
of the best data scientists
statisticians mathematicians out there
it's also had over the last two decades
a very healthy and steady growth but
year after year I hear can our scale can
it deal with very large data sets so
that's what we're here today to do to
talk to you about how you can scale your
our workloads on Google cloud our agenda
for today will be talking about the
evolving our ecosystem on Google cloud
three reference workflows for training
and serving machine learning models one
tensorflow to spark and any our library
that might be a favor of yours finally
with close with a QA with an online Dory
app what is a Dory well it's a Q&A
messaging app that we use internally for
QA at scale to make sure everyone has an
opportunity to ask questions if you go
to our Google cloud next app find our
session you'll see a Dory Q&A link this
will allow you to compose a question as
well as vote to move the good questions
up to the top that you want to see
answered this will actually be open for
the entire week so if we don't get to
all your questions we'll make sure to
answer them directly in the app itself
so let's get started with the art
ecosystem on Google Cloud I posed a
question around can our scale one
response might be does it really matter
is there enough demand for it so two
areas to really look for are distributed
data processing as well as deep learning
to workloads that require lots and lots
of computation and if I do a quick
analysis on cran logs the number of cran
downloads from 2017 q4 vs. 2018 q4
tensorflow and Karis libraries - deep
learning frameworks have doubled in
usage this really is a signal that data
scientists are exploring deep learning
to solve new novel ideas within new
problem domains also sparkly R has
actually grown by 6x during that same
time period a great signal that data
scientists are really pushing the limits
of one machine and the memory that that
really restricts you to and looking for
distributed options on clusters so
Google Cloud should scale I've been at
Google cloud for two years and I will
say I felt neglected as an AR user
of course as a cloud provider developers
were our primary audience we want to
make sure that developers can build
applications on the cloud
we provided client libraries like Java
nodejs golang next we need to help data
engineers build these pipelines and data
stores providing a sequel interface
maybe a Java API for big data frameworks
like Apache beam and then finally
tensorflow is still central to our ml
ecosystem so naturally Python was a
first-class language choice for mo
engineers but after two years a feeling
neglected I really am happy happy to
talk about some of the evolution of
Google cloud to support the art
community natively we do have a lot of
notebook options now we also give you
options to run spot to run spark on a
managed auto scaling spark service allow
you to train tensor flow models or any
custom our library models and really a
big thanks to the overall community
there's a lot of packages that have been
contributed from mark Edmondson Hadley
Wickham in the our studio team to really
interface a lot of the great big data
and ml services that Google Cloud has to
offer so let's talk about how this
actually looks like at the very top we
have lots of different notebook
solutions Zeplin everyone's favorite our
studio our IDE our studio as well as a
man is jupiter notebook with an r kernel
then moving to the very bottom left we
have ingestion and storage options the
two main ones we'll cover today our
Google Cloud Storage our object storage
service really for unstructured data
working with images free text files
audio samples and then for structured
and semi-structured data we have
bigquery are a petabyte scale fully
serverless data warehouse as we move
more into exploratory work and data
profiling what are options to explore
and prepare that data we have a sequel
syntax on top of bigquery that allows
you to crunch through billions of rows
we also have spark again the managed
auto scale and cluster that I talked
about if you want to use some of the
more statistical techniques like PCA or
dimension reduction techniques that are
available through sparks native ml Lib
library now this is where things get
interesting usually I would move on to
the right side and build a custom ml
pipeline but I do want to stop and think
about the bottom middle there where
before you invest time in that you
should actually look into if some of our
pre-trained API
can offer up some solutions that can get
you a good way there we have a lot of
different preacher and api's in the
natural language space the image space
translation audio transcriptions and we
actually have a ml service built
directly into our data warehouse
bigquery and on the right side this is
where we have invested and we believe we
can add value in building a robust ml
pipeline and the three workflows we're
gonna cover today are tensor flow and
kiosks on a managed service called cloud
machine learning engine we'll have
sparks ml Lib library outside of just
the data processing techniques on data
proc and then the number one question
I've gone over the last year is what
about any our library I like to use my
statistics libraries my carrot my are
part how can we use a container based
approach to actually run those at scale
as well so before I jump into the
workflows which will primarily focus on
I want to just give you also two quick
examples of how to embed some of these
workflows upstream so let's say I want
to query lots and lots of data on the
left side I'm loading big R query this
is created by Hadley Wickham and with a
few lines of code
nothing special your normal sequel
syntax but this exact query actually
crunched through a hundred billion rows
three and a half terabytes in 45 seconds
and then it downloads it as a data frame
for you to then run ggplot and other
various analytics and visualization on
top so very powerful for quick
exploratory work and really skit allows
you to push all that scale work to our
managed service and then bring what you
need into your data frame on the other
side of things let's say I work for
customer service and now I want to
analyze all the customer logs for
sentiment and what our customers
actually calling about usually I would
need to go to probably go to school and
get a deep learning degree I would then
maybe have to look for word embeddings
and understand the relationships between
the different words I haven't gone to
creating a labeling data set that is
required for machine learning so before
I invest in all that or hire a team
member who can do that here's a few
lines of code where you can access our
natural language API the Google language
our API that was contributed by Mark
Edmondson it allows you with a few few
lines of code to analyze the text
extract various entities ranked by
salience or importance to classify the
text into various categories as
well as then look at various sentiments
now this might not be your end-all
be-all
this might be an upstream data
enrichment exercise where you then
combine some of these outputs with some
of your structured data to build a more
traditional structured data model so now
let's dive into the actual workflows and
the first one is tensor flow the our
studio team has been working alongside
our tensor flow team to really build a
great set of our api's interfaces on top
of the tensor flow Python modules on the
very left side we have our three core
our packages starting from the bottom we
have tensor flow this is the lowest
level API that allows you to build the
graph of operations gives you the most
flexibility and customization moving up
moving on to the middle TF estimators
this allows you to use out-of-the-box
algorithms regression classification
some of your common neural net
architectures as well as even moving
into spaces like support vector machines
and finally we have Kaos are our top
level high level API that's really built
for usability and quick prototyping and
rapid experimentation and then on the
right side we have a lot of
complementary supporting libraries we
have TF datasets a lot of times when
you're building a machine learning model
the training process doesn't always have
to be your bottleneck it might be how
quick you're feeding all the data and
the appropriate file formats so tftf
data sets allows you to work with
different file types to look at data
data parallel pipelines TF runs tracking
visualizing monitoring those lost curves
looking at evaluation metrics for those
of you who have explored tensorflow
on Python this is very analogous to the
tensor board tool directly in your our
UI third is TF deploy while you'll use
our to build and train your tensor flow
models one of the main powers of tensor
flow it is a language agnostic system a
framework where any other downstream
application whether it be Java c-sharp
can all consume all those predictions so
TF deploy allows you to export and
manage and save all those models moving
forward and then finally our core our
core library cloud ml is an interface to
cloud machine learning engine a managed
service that allows you to provision a
cluster of machines with GPUs or CPUs as
well as also hosting the models as cloud
endpoints for
you to consume in terms of an instance
level or bachelorville prediction so
what does this look like in a more
holistic architecture we do have our
studio server Pro available with
one-click deployment through our GCP
marketplace the code can be version
controlled within a cloud source
repository this is a private git repo
but you're welcome to use github or
bitbucket as well once you package your
tensorflow and then you'll let's say
we're working on a deep learning model
we would store all our images in the
bottom left there with Google Cloud
storage
then we'll package the tensorflow code
and the main piece here again is you
might be doing light development work on
the environment your our studio notebook
is based off of but you're gonna
actually submit the ml training as a job
to cloud machine learning engine you'll
be able to only provision resources for
a number of minutes a number of hours
with the appropriate hardware
accelerators that you need at that time
so it's a very job focused mindset from
an always running development
environment next we're gonna save and
store our results as well as our model
binaries in Google Cloud Storage bucket
and a hierarchy of your choice to really
Virgen them as needed and finally ml
engine also has a secondary module for
serving this is where a model
essentially automatically gets
containerized and hosted as a cloud
endpoint for you to be able to access as
a REST API for instance level one time
predictions maybe for a web or mobile
application or if you need batch
predictions for running through millions
or billions of rows of a table you can
run the batch option as well also
interestingly ml engine is a cloud-based
solution you have to be connected to it
our studio Connect actually is a very
similar offering where you can maybe
host that on-premise on a server as well
and host some of those models where you
might use our burst compute to train the
models but then still want to serve them
on premise and then finally the API call
can be consumed by various downstream
applications whether you stay in the our
ecosystem with our shiny or other mobile
and web applications let's dive a little
bit now into the actual code for
training on cloud ml engine again just
loading the cloud ml library cloud ml
underscore train is the main function
where you actually just point towards
your tensorflow code that's sitting in
our file there's a lot of optional
parameters and this is really where the
power is the master type or the scale
tier allows you to access those
resources for only the time that
training is taken a standard GPU gives
you access to a Nvidia k80
we have a P 100 that's also an option
but if you actually want to even scale
further and have multiple GPUs on one
machine we we have up to 8 V 100's on
one virtual machine with a complex large
model there so with quick plug-and-play
you really have access to various
choices to really optimize both price as
well as performance when you're training
models and thinking about this on a job
job mindset next we have deploy and
predict we're gonna load the cloud ml
library once again once you've really
trained the model you're gonna have a
directory where that model is saved you
can export that model in this case I'm
calling it saved model and then I'm
gonna I'm gonna deploy and host it as an
end point in this case I'll call it
chaos M mist now at that point you have
a lot of different options from
downstream applications but if you want
to run batch predictions or sample
predictions directly in the our
environment you can use the cloud ml
underscore predict options to cycle
through and see whether the images are
being predicted correctly whether audio
samples are being transcribed correctly
or any other traditional structured data
problems that you may be solving so the
great thing is JJ L air from our studio
was actually a next two years ago
introducing a lot of these libraries so
this has been around for almost two
years now so this is a rich ecosystem
where our studio has actually great
resources tutorials gallery samples for
you to take a look at various use cases
across industries everything from
healthcare to traditional
timeseriesforecasting which gets to
boost with deep learning techniques as
well as natural language so please check
that out and there this is probably a
very mature currently out there so now
I'll kick it off to Chris to talk a
little bit about SPARC with our on GCP
Thanks so I am Chris I'm a product
manager here at Google cloud for our
open data and analytics team and I'm
here to talk about how SPARC combined
with Cloud Data proc can help you scale
your our analysis now if you're not
familiar cloud data proc that is our
managed Hadoop and spark
service and many of you probably hear
the word Hadoop and zone out instantly
thinking ok that old legacy technology
and that's you know valid in some ways
but spark is still a very active
community for machine learning in fact
in like two weeks
right here there's going to be a spark a
I conference and the reason why it's
because Apache spark
it's a computing framework that lets you
scale across a cluster of computers in a
generalizable way and that's perfect for
building a rich ecosystem as ml
libraries and the other great thing
about SPARC is it lets us write our our
code and that means that Cloud Data proc
can scale your existing our analysis
without requiring substantial code
rewrites cloud data proc it's often the
fastest way to move your analysis and ml
with our into the cloud so our goal with
Cloud Data proc we want to let you take
the open source tools algorithms and
programming languages like R that you
used today but make it easy to apply
them to cloud scale data sets and then
you can do that without having to manage
tool like clusters and computers now
there's three ways to run our on data
proc today there's our studio which is
the standard web IDE that can be auto
installed on the data proc master node
and then there's two different packages
for running our on SPARC sparkley our
and SPARC are and they have a lot of
similarities but there's some
differences that I'm gonna explain as
well so sparkly our that's a package
working for working with our unspotted I
our studio so you're gonna see a lot of
great hooks and integrations between our
studio and sparkly our SPARC are that's
built directly into SPARC itself and so
you're gonna find great hooks there with
things like Cloud Data procs jobs API
which and that jobs API that makes it
really easy to submit jobs through
submit our jobs through things like the
g-cloud command or an HTTP endpoint so
you
can build automated tooling around your
are on your are code but what I'd like
to do now is just take a quick peek
under the hood of both spark R and
sparkly to help you understand how these
tools actually scale your in our
analysis so this is a very high level
spark our architecture there's two
pieces to spark there's going to be the
spark driver and then the spark workers
again very high level but oftentimes
this spark driver depending on what mode
of spark you're in that's often going to
run exactly where you're our studio is
running and you're gonna spin up what's
called a spark our context you can think
about that essentially as a client for
calling into spark now under the hood
what happens in that spark our context
is there's a bridge it's done over a
socket layer that's going to translate
your our code into Java code and then
there's a Java spark context that's
actually going to scale your work across
the various spark executors you can
think of those basically as nodes in the
cluster at a high level now what's going
to happen from those spark executors is
it's going to actually make a call out
to a local version of our and so that's
real R that means any package that you
can take with R and scale you can scale
with spark the spark our rather because
this is real our code that you're
running at the once it's broken up now
alternative architecture to that is
sparkly R now what sparkly R does
instead is they're gonna serialize the
information into Apache Aero and that
means in terms of ml algorithm and then
what they do is they call out they use
that information to call out to the
spark ml package so that means in terms
of machine learning you're gonna be
limited to the functionality that exists
in the spark ml package so there are
some now despite that there are some
pretty cool features I found with
sparkly are that are missing from spark
R so for instance they do have a direct
integration with crayon they have an
extra boost extension and they also
integrate with broom if you're not
familiar with broom
it's
pretty pretty neat ml package it takes
the output of a lot of unstructured
messy datasets like if you have a bunch
of t-tests and it comes back as a bunch
of unstructured information it'll it'll
take a broom we'll take it and turn into
a nice tidy data frame that'll let you
look at results of multiple models at
once pretty quickly it's pretty it's
interesting so of course this is gonna
beg the question I'm sure everyone has
right now okay what do you want me to
use bar car or sparkly are so spark are
you I find that folks use it a little
bit more for automation first of all
it's built into the cloud data proc and
to spark itself so you get a little bit
better performance but sparkly R again
that's coming from the tidy our studio
team so that does have tend to have a
little bit better integrations with our
studio spark our that comes from amp lab
the same people who did spark so you're
gonna find that they are gonna follow
things in a little bit more spark first
kind of way in other words it's gonna
follow mostly the Scalla way of doing
things
whereas sparkley are they think a little
bit more are first and then sometimes
they'll do an hour integration at the
sacrifice of something like performance
but both their active projects and so
when there are examples like that what
you find is they tend to get resolved
pretty quickly so oftentimes it just
comes down to where do you want to spend
your time automating our code spark our
or is it you know working with
interactive or studio type analysis and
you go sparkly are but if you're still a
little confused on the difference in
what to use don't worry I probably am
too but luckily I found it's not really
an issue to use both so all you once you
load the sparkly is the spike lay our
package you can then just call into
spark our it does step on some of the
deep liar functions but as long as you
mask it correctly you can go ahead and
use both and a code a set of code that
has both sparkly R and spark are can be
submitted to the data props API so what
I'm gonna do now is I would like to
quickly walk through a example of how
you can use Cloud Data proc to scale
some our analysis and what I'm going to
show you is a common model like the one
that you see here
we're gonna run through a workflow where
the data starts in bigquery which is
often in common store for semi
structured or structured data sets we're
gonna spin up an auto scaling cloud data
proc cluster to actually do our machine
learning and then we're gonna say the
output of that model into Google Cloud
storage and that way later on when I
want to rerun this I'm going to use a
cloud data proc workflow template which
is a set it's basically a graph of jobs
that what you can send a data proc it'll
spin up a right size cluster to run
those jobs run those jobs make sure that
the cluster is torn down and then save
all the output of what happened and all
the logs into stackdriver so how do you
want to take over on your laptop flip
over okay
go ahead and kick us off okay so
essentially I'm a product manager here
at Google cloud so a lot of time I spend
essentially you know building articles
or blogs that I put out onto the
internet and what I really love what do
I really love to have it's a machine
learning model that would read my blog
and then say you know how successful is
this gonna be on the internet and that
might give me an opportunity to go back
and tweak some things before I actually
go and try to publish it so whenever I'm
looking for data sets like this I always
start with big queries public datasets
program that has over a hundred eighty
different publicly available datasets
they're stored for free that I can take
and use to augment my analysis and what
I do and what I'm doing here is I found
a great data set for Hacker News and
hacker news data set it has basically a
score which is how well that article did
on the internet that score is a
combination of upvotes and real inks and
it also has the full-text of the article
so I can use that to train now what
you're seeing in this query here is just
I'm taking scores greater than zero and
a length of text greater than zero only
to get a nice clean data set because
what I'm trying to do here is although
bigquery is awesome at sequel I wanted
to take advantage of our and some of the
machine learning capabilities that cloud
data proc and offer me so what I'm going
to do is just going to put this into a
a table I could go directly with the
query but I'm just gonna make it easy on
myself and take a thousand rows sample
and just put it into this hacker news
sample data set and you can see in the
bottom of the screen here you can see
what I'm getting back which is a score
that I'm gonna use for a label along
with the full text so once that job has
actually completed what I'm gonna do is
I'm going to jump back over to cloud
data proc and I'm going to click on my
cluster and I'm gonna come into a web
interface using our component gateway we
expose various web UIs that are running
on your cluster and then we make sure
that you can come into those using your
cloud iam credentials so you saw me just
jump into Zeppelin which is a spark
based notebook but it also can work with
R and so the first thing that you're
seeing me do here is just that same
query I ran in bigquery I could have run
that directly in Zeppelin there is an
interpreter so I'm just showing that but
what I'm doing or what I really want to
do is I'm gonna run this Python function
that's going to let me take that an
arbitrary tables with my hacker news
sample and pull that into a spark data
frame now once that's into a spark data
frame I'm just gonna do a quick count to
establish that hey there's a thousand
rows in that sample that matches my
limit so I'm probably on the right track
now what I want to do is I'm going to
register this data frame and so that
with one line I'm gonna register my data
frame as a temp table and that's gonna
let me work with this same exact data
frame across all the languages of spark
so that Scala sequel Python or I can go
back and forth without having to move in
the structure or data around it's all in
the same data frame and you can see now
that I can start to do some of my basic
are explorations things that look
completely normal like filtering on data
per you know scores greater than 50 but
I can now do this on cloud scale data
sets instead of just you know R the R
that's running on my laptop now there's
two ways I can actually scale analysis
using spark first off this is an example
where I'm just going to to to bunt have
sent a GLM across a spark and send it
with a lot of different hyper parameters
so I can tune a lot of
smaller models at once with different
hyper parameters get those all in a list
and then analyze which model may be
perform the best but in this example
here I'm actually not going to do that
list apply I'm gonna do a D apply
because I just want to run you know one
you know NLP package that I love in
spark across that whole dataset of
hacker news now in this case I just have
my thousand samples that came back but
this is enough where I'm saying yep I
think I'm in the right track of this
model so what I want to do now is I'm
going to go back up to the function
where I was calling my sample table and
I'm now gonna change that to the full
hacker news data set so the entire
corpus corpus of notes not just my
sample and then just by clicking this
off I'm going to rerun all that same
code you just saw except this time on
the full hacker news data set and as
this kicks off what I'd realize this
kicks off what I want to do is come back
into data proc and take a look at what's
happening underneath the hood so I
started with three vm's which is totally
fine for my thousand node sample size
manipulating the data and getting ready
but about two minutes later on the large
data set as I'm pulling that data in
from bigquery the data proc autoscaler
says hey you need a little bit more help
let me add a couple notes to their
cluster then a few minutes later there's
another spike in the yarn memory usage
which is because I'm actually now
training on that text data so the
cluster got even bigger but once that
model training completes I just
refreshed the page and the data proc
autoscaler has said okay I've used all
the memory I need and it scales my
cluster back down for me and so all of
that was able to occur without me ever
changing from the notebook I didn't
change environments I just click run and
Cloud Data practice Kahler knew how to
respond finally if I wanted to save this
model off and not keep a running cluster
but have something else around I have it
around I could create a workflow
template and I'm not going to step
through all of the steps here but
essentially it would end up looking like
this in the console where at any time if
I wanted to rerun all this with the
associated cluster I would just click
run and that would be it alright we can
flip back to the slide
now so if you want to go and get started
and do that exact same analysis this
code is what I use to spin up the
cluster it's pretty straightforward
it's just I'm calling into cloud data
proc I'm saying use the optional
components of Jupiter Zeppelin anaconda
in this example you could also throw in
our studio I used
Epling because I wanted to go cross
languages but you could definitely use
our studio with this initialization
action and then I installed a bigquery
connector and the enable component
gateway that would expose those web UI
links for me and made sure that I had
permission to get into them and finally
the auto scaling policy you can actually
tune the auto scaling policy to you know
there's a lot of knobs that we expose if
you don't care about those knobs you
don't have to use them but they are
exposed if you want to - in the settings
of the autoscaler - how aggressive you
want it or how often you want to scale
so with that I'm going to hand over to
Greg
all right thanks everyone for joining us
this morning so we heard about some
great ways to leverage tensorflow and
spark ecosystems using our GCP but what
about the cases where you need to train
and deploy a model using any our library
so let's look at an end-to-end solution
for this so first we need to set up a
development environment and cloud ml
notebooks is a great tool on google
cloud for data scientists to do this we
can get started with one-click easily
scale up with compute engine machine
types at a remove GPUs as necessary
leverage both R and Python from the
notebook and enable team collaboration
with git integration and cloudy I hub we
can publish notebooks to cloud AI hub
specifically for our users we can get
started in four steps so we can launch a
PI torch ml notebook which has Conda
installed and this is going to make it
easier to install our our base package
in libraries we're also going to load
the our PI - extension to enable our
cell magic and this is what allows us to
run both R and Python for but in the
same notebook we're gonna create a
directory in our home folder for
libraries so we can install our own
libraries and you know have right access
to that directory but what should we do
in those situations where resources on
our development workstation aren't
adequate like running out of memory when
working with a large data set so let's
look at how we can package our code in
containers for running on cloud ml
engine and kubernetes engine for those
just getting started with containers you
can think of them as a method for
packaging an app with its dependencies
for running on a variety of platforms
not just on ml engine so in the next
demo I'll walk through building a
pipeline based on this architecture
we're going to import and analyze our
data with bigquery
so we're gonna use standard sequel to
query our data set stage it as a CSV
file in Google Cloud Storage we'll write
a training application with Jupiter with
ml notebooks and R and we'll package
this up with docker and send it over to
ml engine will write the app such that
the assets the model assets that are
created by the training app or stored in
Google Cloud storage and we'll take
these assets and package them in another
container that we can deploy for serving
and this will leverage Google Cooper
nice engine Seldon an STI alright great
so first we'll navigate over to ml
engine and ml l notebooks I already have
or we could create a new instance PI
torch but I already have one created so
we're gonna open this one to start and
I'm gonna I pulled some code from from
github so I'm gonna start here with a
notebook I've already created
I have Conda I've used Kondo to install
our PI two already so I'll go ahead and
load the extension I've created a
directory for my libraries and I can go
and check this out and see that I've
installed some already and I have access
to them
and then I can use the R sell magic next
to you know install whatever library I
need and then we want to get data from
bigquery so we can use the bigquery cell
magic and then our data will be exported
into a data frame which we can then
import into R so then once it's in our
you know we can view the structure of
the data that we've pulled in here we're
looking at public baby weight data from
bigquery and we can also build a model
just a traditional linear model just to
get started but we want to do more than
that you know we want it so let's take
this data and stage it in cloud storage
so we can run some other models and we
can scale it up to ml engine so I'm
going to go into the bigquery console
and take that query and paste it in
there and this can be done from you know
within our using the API but it's just
as easy to use the console
so first I'm querying about 68,000 rows
just for testing so I'm gonna have to to
CSV files and I'll export this directly
to Google Cloud Storage and this is my
storage bucket the you know train data
small is going to be that file and then
I'll change this query to sample a bit
more data and we'll use this data set
for when we scale to ml engine so when
this finishes we'll see that we have
about 13 million rows you can also see
that we're doing a little bit of
pre-processing in the query and it's
it's good to keep in mind that bigquery
is very performant for
preprocessing data with sequels so this
would be a good case to use sequel for
some of that instead of our potentially
so we'll export this CSV to cloud
storage and now we've got my data I've
got my data staged for training so I'll
head back over to Jupiter and I'll start
working on writing my training app so
first I create this trainer folder that
you can see on the Left sidebar there
and I'm gonna create a file for
installing my our dependencies first I'm
going to set a library path based on an
environment variable and then I'll
specify the packages I need and then in
the training app I'm going to specify
that same library path I'm going to
configure command line arguments for
Google Cloud storage for training data
for the export directory I'm gonna use
carrot to impute missing values Center
and scale my data I'm going to change
you know the the factors or the features
I need two factors partition the data
into tests and train set up hyper
parameter tuning cross-validation and
then I can kick off my training job
using GM GL m-net for this example and
when the training is complete it's going
to save my model file as well as my
pre-processing waits to Google Cloud
Storage and I could also export you know
any additional assets that I wanted like
if I wanted to export plots you know or
other results then I'll go into docker
to package all of this I'll take the
base our image I'll install the Google
SDK so I can download my files from
cloud storage I'll copy over that file
too or that script to install packages
set the library environment variable
I'll copy over the training app and then
I'll use entry point to tell ml engine
hey this is the script that's going to
run when the container kicks off so
before we go ahead and deploy the
container to container registry let's
just make sure the training app runs
locally and then we'll get the model
file saved and then we'll also test
inference this is an end-to-end
deployment so we want to make sure
inference works as well as training
before we go ahead and start training on
ml engine so we see we get a result
returned so we'll go ahead and build the
the docker image and package up our our
training container
and then we can deploy it to Google
Google container registry and once it's
in container registry it's accessible to
ml Engine so we'll submit a job
referencing that container reference our
training data in the storage bucket the
output directory and we can also specify
a machine type or a cluster of machines
here with accelerators if necessary so
when the job is submitted we can go back
over to the console and use ml engine to
view the job running we'll be able to
see our utilization metrics and our logs
and you can add additional logs as
needed you know based on your training
app when the model is complete the model
assets are written to cloud storage so
we can go into cloud storage and see you
know the assets from the prior jobs that
have run so I've got a few folders here
from prior jobs and we'll look at the
most recent and here we can see the
model RDS file and the pre-processing
weights so then let's go back into
Jupiter and let's serve our completed
model so we're going to install s2i
which is source to image it's a tool
that's just going to make it easier to
build the the container image without a
docker file essentially source to image
and Seldon require this environment file
they requires and installed at our file
which is installs the dependencies we're
going to download the model assets from
Google Cloud Storage and include them in
the container and then we're going to
set up a runtime file which is going to
load the RDS model file the
pre-processing file it's going to take
the input from prediction do the
pre-processing and then evaluate against
the model so once we have all these
files we can call s2i to build our
serving image so very easy we don't even
have to build a docker file here we just
build our our files for serving and then
package up our image we can test it
locally and then run a request against
it locally we see we get what we were
expecting so we can also view logs if we
needed a debug and then stop the
container to restart it so we'll go
ahead and push the working container
that we have it's
container registry and if we didn't have
a cluster already started we would we
would create one kubernetes cluster we
can see that we already have one running
so we'll deploy the application to the
cluster we have a running and then
verify that it's been deployed and that
the the pod is running for the
application and then we'll explode
expose that a deployment on port 80 and
then get an external IP address for the
app so we have our external IP address
we can make another request and we see
the result we were expecting so it looks
like we're good to go a nice thing with
kubernetes engine are managed kubernetes
service we can go into the console and
view the pod the application running we
can see utilization metrics and we can
view logs from the container as well so
with that I'll pass it back over to
Mikael to wrap up for us thank you
thanks Greg
so just just in closing hopefully this
image makes a little bit more sense I
think at the very top starting with the
notebooks think some of the key ways we
saw Chris talk about the new web
interfaces module within data product
allows you to quickly spin up these
notebooks ml notebooks actually is an a
managed Jupiter service that went also
beta on March 1st so also a new service
that then maybe a lot of you may not
have heard of before but we really made
sure that all both demos as well as my
my reference architecture showcased all
three so you got a sense of how each of
those three look like we also walked
through different storage techniques
both from bigquery as well as GCS and
from a spark perspective think the auto
scaling is something that I've really
been using quite a bit myself as well as
working with a lot of customers because
there is no need to then necessarily
right-size your workloads or maybe have
a little bit more capacity than you need
sitting idle that auto scaling feature
really has a certain logic built in when
when the number of clusters grow and
then on the very bottom right what Greg
walk through you will make sure to
provide that that in terms of github
code but the key takeaway is again
hybrid and portable these were all
containers you can use them on Google
Cloud you can train or create a serving
application
those are fully portable to be ported
over to another cloud onto on-premise
and Seldon specifically the serving the
serving approach that greg walked
through that's part of the broader cube
flow ecosystem where we are making it
very easy easy connectors to the
kubernetes ecosystem a quick cheat sheet
around both the services and libraries
it is quite a bit and we'll try to get
some resources out there online but the
first two rows really talk about the
data ingestion GCP services as well as
the are packages that allow you to
access these very quickly directly in
our code we walk through different ways
of doing that within your our code as
well as directly in the console whatever
you're more comfortable with various
options there and then the bottom three
talk about the training service the
serving service and then the actual our
library packages that you can you can
leverage to access that and in a
familiar environment now the last column
of course you know that does require a
little bit of container knowledge docker
kubernetes but really really does
future-proof yourself and makes makes a
lot of your workloads portable moving
forward so what now we have a couple of
bit late links for the SPARC ecosystem
christed published a blog post a few
months back that's a great primer on how
to get running with SPARC on data proc
tensorflow to our studio comm is a great
repository for resources and our studio
and JJ actually partnered with the
creator of chaos to publish a book I'm
deep learning with R as well as the
great cheat sheets that our studio is
known for and then I mentioned the
examples that Greg walk through a lot of
great information that github link is
there under G Michaels his github Gabe
name along with Google Cloud our
examples as well as some Billy links for
a new feature with in machine learning
engine as well for custom containers as
well as cue flow and Selden
[Music]